[Music]
it goes down back to this lack of
transparency and it frankly it reeks of
an attempt to conceal what happened
a lawyer speaking out saying there is a
district-wide failure in properly
training special needs teachers at Clark
County Schools he is representing a mom
who claims her special needs child was
abused by a teacher a police report
uncovered several issues including
teachers not immediately reporting abuse
as they are required to do under law
Joshua paguero looks into the case joins
us now live from our Newsroom
Roger says she started noticing changes
in her daughter's Behavior after she was
enrolled at Kirk Adams Elementary then a
few weeks later her suspicions were
confirmed
she's non-verbal she can't say anything
she's not able to tell me anything so by
me seeing her behavior off I just didn't
I couldn't figure out what the issue was
in December of 2022 dejiana Rogers
received a report from ccsdpd they gave
her some answers it details how a
special needs teacher reportedly
physically assaulted her daughter on
several occasions and after one of the
incidents investigators say a teacher's
aide stated that since the incident
occurred sinai's demeanor has changed
and she has been crying every day won't
smile
Sanai Wears Like braces and we have her
teacher who picks up her chair and dumps
her out of the chair onto the floor
because she's not happy that Sanai is
not getting up quickly enough Greg
Hubley is representing Rogers in this
matter ccsdpd concluded in the report
that quote this case should be handled
administratively as the reported actions
of the teacher do not rise to the level
of a criminal act end quote I was really
confused by it because I thought
physical punishment was a criminal act
Child Protective Services also found the
allegations
unsubstantiated but humbly sees several
problems under state law teachers are
mandatory reporters meaning if they
witness any physical abuse of a child
they're required to report it within 24
hours
Hubley says that didn't happen here a
Sanai was abused observed being abused
by this teacher in mid-november it was
reported to the principal in early
December and it wasn't
dejiana as the mother was not informed
until four or five days later
now Hubley says a teacher accused of
abusing Sanaya still teaching at Kirk
Adams Elementary while Sanaya was moved
to another school at this moment they
have yet to follow a lawsuit as they're
seeking to settle this matter out of
court Brian